[Music]
frankly heart what is it telling you
they're scary
more than I've ever been in my life and
I am NOT alone
there's someone in Hell's Kitchen that
wants to control our city our lives but
no one knows who it is or what they want
we don't say his name the city needs to
die before it can be reborn you ever
heard the name Wilson Fisk
explosion stunt Hell's Kitchen earlier
tonight you think Fisk that's something
you're doing this I do what are we
supposed to do against somebody that
owns everything everyone you can't give
in to the fear what are you gonna do
whatever it takes
you're blind there are other ways to see
that guy in the mask saved my life
I'm just trying to make my city a better
place
we both can't have what we want so
you're part yes tonight I'm going to
find you then I'm gonna make you pay for
what you've done
admire her conviction the lone man
thinks he can make a difference
get out of my city
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so the final
daredevil trailers just posted and I had
a chance to go see the premiere the
first two episodes so I'm gonna do a
non-spoilery review of that here's the
important information so next Friday is
when all the episodes are supposed to
drop there's 13 total if you're looking
for comics to read first start with
Frank Miller's miniseries Maine without
fear that's what the TV show is adapted
from the TV shows an adaptation to that
storyline after that read Brian Michael
Bendis is run from 2001 to 2006 that's
like that's a lot of comics so you don't
have to read everything but generally
the tone of his run is closest to what
Frank Miller's was like a gritty crime
drama with superheroes in it instead of
being like a traditional superhero story
Frank Miller's awesomeness is
self-explanatory the reason everyone
likes Bendis so much is because after
Frank Miller left the the title
subsequent writers made the tone like
really light-hearted and jokey Bendis
was the one that turned it back into a
crime drama if you've been a little
turned off by how disney some of the ABC
shows like agents of shield agent carter
feel like they just feel like very safe
just because they can't do as much blood
or gore or crazy action daredevil is the
antidote to that because they're on
Netflix they don't have as many
restrictions lots more sex lots more
violence so if that's what you've been
looking for then daredevil is the answer
to that daredevil is your antidote a lot
of you guys are asking questions about
how the Netflix series are gonna overlap
with each other what's gonna happen is
is they'll have all 13 episodes of
daredevil then after the finale the
first episode of Jessica Jones will pick
up so the timeline will work kind of
like the movies where it's all
sequential I don't know if Jessica Jones
is gonna premiere in the fall or if
it'll be next spring they haven't
confirmed a premiere date so when they
do I'll just all update one of my videos
but generally expect them to premiere
two TV series per year because there's
only 13 episodes that way we get to like
the defenders team up relatively quickly
within a couple years and yes the
producers have said that they are
planning for daredevil season 2 but it
hasn't been confirmed yet they haven't
announced daredevil season 2 yet so the
first two episodes are really mostly
meant just to kind of immerse you in the
world of daredevil like it looks very
different from any other Marvel series
you've ever watched it was shot
completely on location in New York City
they were probably a few scenes that
they had to shoot inside a studio with a
little
green screen work but for the most part
you can tell when they shoot on location
there's this brain-melting shot of New
York City at nighttime that you could
tell they shot on location and I think
shooting on location is one of the
reasons why this series looks way better
than any of the other Marvel TV series
it looks way better than agents of
shield
even though shield is a network show
with a way bigger cast if you guys have
ever watched arrow imagine like season 1
of that when the show is way more urban
imagine that with like all the dials
cranked up to 11
just like everything going crazy I think
the series benefits from having a much
smaller cast like you just get to spend
much more time with each character it's
much more intimate in its localized in
Hell's Kitchen the story is and because
of the way Daredevils powers work his
echolocation
everything is very claustrophobic like
he needs physical objects for sound to
bounce off of for his echolocation to
work the way it's supposed to so he
tends to avoid big open spaces they
completely nailed the pacing I mean
there's there's a lot of humor a lot of
action and you just get like right into
it right away there's no wasting time I
mentioned it in some of my earlier
Marvel videos but Marvel is like slowly
moving away from the traditional origin
story like there is an origin story in
this comic it does tell you his
backstory but it does so using a series
of targeted flashbacks like things will
happen in present day that will trigger
flashbacks and that's how they break up
the origin story like the really
important moments from his childhood
it's a lot like the way arrow uses
flashbacks to inform what's going on in
the present like both the flashbacks and
the present-day scenes work together to
move the narrative forward I would
generally expect that the movies like
post age of Ultron post ant-man will
slowly move towards a narrative
structure that's a little closer to this
like they'll have new characters like
Doctor Strange Captain Marvel
they'll have to explain their
backstories what they'll probably do is
just break it up in flashbacks like you
have all these really complicated
characters you need to explain but you
don't have spent so much time explaining
who they are that it takes you out of
the main story thus we arrive at
staggered flashbacks most of you should
enjoy it most of the actors you may not
be very familiar with there are a couple
like rosario Dawson and Vincent and
opera are you pricing them before
Charlie Cox though hasn't done a whole
lot of big stuff he did have a run on
Boardwalk Empire recently and he also
just starred in the Stephen Hawking
movie with Eddie Redmayne but the
characters he played in those
are vastly different from Matt Murdock
and daredevil so it's not like you need
to rush out and watch that stuff before
you see daredevil the same goes for most
of the other characters this meant
especially like Vincent D'Onofrio his
villain you guys are gonna be really
excited he is not like any other villain
that we've seen in the Marvel Universe
I'd say of all the characters that have
potential to crossover with the movies
his character his villain character
kingpin and daredevil or probably the
top of the list they just started
shooting civil war this week they
started on April 1st
Donofrio said that he'd love to have a
cameo so it made it sound like he's not
in it right now but for the most part
daredevil is relatively landlocked to
Hell's Kitchen and yes they do invoke
the movies like that the pre-existing
cannon in a really funny interesting way
no spoilers for that yet but you guys
will really like the way they do it I
was really happy with the way Charlie
Cox the actor was able to pull off both
the different personas for Matt Murdock
like Matt Murdock during the day then
you have daredevil in the costume at
night two completely different people
the one common denominator but between
those two personas is the dry wit he's
not like a wisecracker like spider-man
is but he does have this subtle sense of
humor that's really consistent and he
totally nailed the fight scenes to super
parkour super badass so he can do the
action and he could do the humor like I
said that I've only seen the first two
episodes so there's probably a lot of
situations a lot of like character
moments that I haven't seen yet that's
kind of where we get the introduction to
Rosario Dawson's character Claire temple
she plays a nurse in this storyline so
she's very important to daredevil
because he's a street-level hero so as
much as he kicks ass he gets his ass
kicked
really it seems like that like when he
gets his ass kicked that you start to
feel the stakes they do a really good
job on the show of making things feel as
dire as they do during age of Ultron
like a 150 million dollar movie that's
really where I think the series winds
above a lot of the other Marvel shows
like you just don't feel the big stakes
in agents of shield the way you do in
the movies maybe they started breaking
more people's arms or like stabbing
people in the chest they did splatter
Bill Paxton at the end of last season
most of like the really obvious humor
and the series comes from the foggy
Nelson character you know you might not
be super familiar with him from the
comics he like he and Matt Murdock form
like this comedic duo but the funny part
is is that Matt Murdock gets most of the
laughs foggy Nelson it plays more like
the obvious humor he's kind of like the
guy that reacts to Matt Murdock and
all those situations they get into the
other two really important actors you
need to pay attention to our young Matt
Murdock and his father battlin Jack
Murdock remember I said they basically
they break the flashbacks up to tell the
origin story if you've read the comic
book you don't see a whole lot of his
father in that so I also think they
expanded his role for the TV series he
has his own really awesome arc that
informs where the adult Matt Murdock is
coming from emotionally we Murdock's
we get knocked down a lot but we always
get back up there's also some really fun
Easter eggs and those flashback scenes
for where the characters head it so that
like you know by the time he becomes
complete daredevil like the WC in the
comics they've arrived they're
organically it it all makes sense it's
not like he just wakes up one day and
says I'm gonna wear a costume that looks
like this I'm gonna use weapons that
work like this so you don't have to read
the comics but but it is a little bit of
fun like you might want to watch the TV
series and then read the comics and
another thing to be really excited about
is they shot the series in 4k so if
you're able to stream Netflix and 4k you
can actually watch the series in 4k
there aren't a whole lot of people that
are doing that right now the thing that
Netflix is doing is that they're
overspending just a little bit to make
their series their original series look
a little more cinematic just to give you
an idea like in terms of like budget
Game of Thrones is really like The Lost
leader
HBO spends about six million dollars in
episode on that so it's like 60 million
I'd say daredevil spent closer to like
50 maybe 55 million on 13 episodes so
it's not like crazy game of Thrones
level but it's way more than a normal TV
series a normal Network TV series might
only spend like four million dollars for
a really big episode so when you watch
it you'll understand like why it looks
so much better than agents of shield but
just to be clear that's not a knock on
agents of shield it's a very different
type of TV series made in a very
different format so what's gonna happen
is is next Friday I'm gonna do a video
for like the first three episodes like a
spoiler video be sure to subscribe to
get that I will do episode videos but
instead of doing like it I do for agents
of shield and do like one video per
episode I'll probably do like one video
for every three episodes I'm also
planning on working in like a couple
character bonus videos throughout so
like whenever we get to special
characters I'll probably try and do
bonus video for them I know everyone's
asking about Elektra she hasn't been
completely omitted from the Canon but
the showrunner has been very mum about
whether she is or is not in the series
just in case you guys haven't seen it I
did a king
video little while ago you can click
here to watch that and you can click
here to watch my latest Game of Thrones
video that is premiering the same
weekend that daredevil drops so get
really excited for that let's start
humming the Game of Thrones theme so
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight